we were talking about you know Matt
Gates before we we launched the show
here but Matt Gates takes zero dollars
from special interest groups or packs
he's was the first Republican politician
to say I don't want your money yeah
Barack Obama spent more money than
anyone ever and then Hillary Clinton did
the same thing and Donald Trump didn't
spend more money than everyone and he
still won you know so so it makes money
what makes me a big fan of these Mega
politicians from president Trump to Matt
Gates is they would rather have small
dollar donations from hard-working
Americans then go and kiss the asses of
the club for gross of the world who
receive you know 200 million dollars
from five people and then they have to
take marching orders president Trump
when he ran in 2020 53 percent of his
dollars came from small dollar very
small dollar donors Ron DeSantis on the
flip side right now 95 of his donations
come from 500 people and he raised 200
million dollars